okay so this is a poem is that a boy poo
hotel avoid say like pool boy alright go
boy
so okay you got me Jason and pillow Jory
I say hi pillow Tori don't beat your
wife what's wrong with you you should do
this oh shut up I never liked pillow
Joey almost as bad as cat Jory we've
made like so many different Jory sit
sort of like the various princesses they
had actually Jory and flame Jory so shut
up your dad pillow
Jory so silence yes okay good I think
you're dead very good oh I'm conflicted
this is all right so this is oh my god I
love this episode I love it's I think
the concept is so funny and so imagine
it is it's just this is what that last
episode should have been yeah this is
what it was probably trying to do and
it's both this be colossal epic episode
it's also kind of a huge waste of time
and the exact same time and they're both
so good at being that it's like both
really deep and meaningful and kind of
beautiful and it's also like just
totally pointless and meaningless and
it's I love this episode
okay so Finn it's another was it nice
store or whatever the other is raining
swords or whatever and so they make a
pillow for it inside and Finn's feel bad
cuz affordable all frickin a pillow yes
and Finn's feeling bad because he told
Flame Princess a joke and she didn't get
a taste wonder if that means it's over
now because he knows nothing about where
and how fairy watch about relationships
and he says he's gonna go as pillow for
it to think about it and it's so big and
massive that comes across this door like
this dimension to this pillow world and
the pillow world looks wonderful i mean
it is so creative and it's beautifully
drawn and it's so funny and he fights a
pillow dragon blanket dragon a blanket
dread that's a blanket tiger and saves
the pillow people and he comes across
what was it the daughter of quilting was
that it yeah probably something we have
Roslyn yeah and it's just like oh I
could just stay for a little bit and
sure enough like just a few seconds in
whoo results in like years and years
going by and he grows into Jonathan
Frakes and you know it he has kids he
just lives out his lifetime and it's
like it's a good life I mean it's like a
really you know event filled you know
loving live eats he's got a wonderful
family and he he keeps busy and uh but
he's still kind of looking for his
portal to get back home and finally he
has a chance to get it but he decides
not to because he loves his new family
and everything so he lives literally
till his dying day he yellow and somehow
he lost the the arm which again is sort
of the mechanical now arm pillow arm I
should say in this sense and he passes
away and he travels back while bumping
into some sort of evil red Lego and he
comes out the other end and just thinks
it's all a dream and there's no Flame
Princess just got the joke and he
completely forgets about it and it's
what do you even say about it it's just
so funny and it's and it's so huge and
epic and I love these stories where you
know somebody goes and lives like a
lifetime and you kind of feel like they
lived a lifetime mm-hmm uh and again in
11 minutes they've got this wild they
could also cut back to seeing Jake and
beemo you know just sort of be silly oh
you've been got a little bit of a talk
about like Jake you know being a dad for
only a few hours and
missing you know being a father I was
like how can they fit all this in so
well in 11 minutes um now do you see why
when I say glitch is a glitch that jokes
when I'm too long this one was like boom
boom boom boom the jokes were there the
story was there glitch was a glitch
there were so few jokes and everything
was just kind of dragged out this is
what I'm talking about everything was
there in 11 minutes and it felt like
there was no missed opportunity yeah I
mean you just feel like you kind of feel
like you watched a lifetime you know in
this guy and that just makes it all the
more funny when she travels back he's
just like an whatever cuz I was trying
to watch yourself oh so like how are
they going to end this I mean yes it's
gonna end like on this really big
serious note or is it just gonna be a
dumbell joke
either way it's like I'm gonna love it
if they do it right oh they did it great
um and it's fitting that the guy
Jonathan Frakes has grown up in because
I think there was like a Star Trek
episode where Patrick Stewart the exact
same thing happens like he travels to a
different world where he lives a
lifetime pretty much and then like he
ends up dying there and it turns out it
was all a probe to put in his mind of
this dying civilization so that they can
live on and somebody can know about
their civilization because they're now
extinct you know and then he wakes up
but it's like unlike Finn he that you
know he feels like he lived a lifetime
and he's still getting used to being
captain again and stuff it's actually
really good at the same time I forget
the title but it's very very good
uh and it reminded me of that and that's
that's actually found like the best dug
version of that kind of concept I've
ever seen of living an entire life but
coming back you know sort of to a
reality after living that life and yeah
it's just but I love this ending with
Jesse Oh what was it huh the dream so I
loved it how about you I just really
liked how you said it right the design
of the pillow world was just phenomenal
everything was a pillow like for the
most part there was a few blankets but
every time he quilt
like everything was a pillow and there's
been numerous like other worlds that
people have gone to in movies or TV
shows where it's like oh this is the
blank world's and it's like oh it's got
this but it still heads like cars or
this side of the other thing what I love
is to see you see this car pull up and
it's just to play them yeah there is no
like cogs there is none of that stuff in
this world it is just pillows and
blankets and I really love that they
actually completely stuck to that even
if you look at the sky it looks like a
blanket with some stitching in it and
that takes I mean I know people be like
well how difficult is that it's it's
it's difficult to design a world to make
it look good and have everything be this
one thing and not have it be a repeat of
the same thing over ever to make it all
look different even though the little
pillow people have to look a little bit
different and have unique designs and
yeah I think the hours like going this
toy boy keep talking well I what I was
kind of waiting for initially the first
time I saw this was for there to be a
pillow Jake pillow Bubblegum a pillow
Marceline they never went that route
which I love that
I love the fact that they never went
down that route of oh let's bring in all
the characters we already know and love
but just pillow versions of them you
know because those kind of things always
bother me like a good example is when so
lets us all I never wish I was alive and
then you saw the world where they would
be if they were not alive for life but
it's one of those things where it's like
yeah but some of these characters never
would have met the other person if it
wasn't for you so they wouldn't have any
connection anyways but you can't break
up that connection you've already made
like Futurama did it where if you never
went to the past you know what would
help
and it shows like this dimensional rift
you see Leela bender and Farnsworth and
it's like none of those would have met
each other if it wasn't for fry fry meet
Lulu she is and bender who he is and
they met because Barnes was because of
him it's like so no you're not following
it but I love and this is is that it's
not that stuff they don't try to cram in
these characters that never would have
met each other anything like that it's a
whole new world which I think most
kind of forgets welcome it's Oh
well first of all I love the fact that
they can you know we've heard a lot of
puns like whatever in the Flintstones or
was that Gnomeo and Juliet or so they
heard there's nothing but like bad gnome
yeah it's really yeah but I got every
time they say it's the pillow
Necronomicon up the pillow blanket
dragon it's a it's like they every time
they say you know he tries the try our
pillow food or some pillow yes
thank the pillow if they deliver it just
right and they know just the right
amount to give before it gets tiring and
then I don't hello pillows and blankets
are for sleeping and she goes sing here
silly as she's slowly winking haha like
it's nice that they have that joke in
there that little you know I didn't even
catch that you're right in space gets
old
his chief skill oh you're right Oh bird
poop yeah with the pillowcase or
whatever
no they just poop real poop um like yeah
you know you're talking about like how
so many of these shows when they create
an alternate world yeah it's our like
just a parallel universe where
everything kind of looks the same
whatever I'm thinking to this show it's
like yeah by god I mean even the worlds
in or different dimensions or into just
something in a pill for it I mean the
time and effort that just goes in these
worlds and they all have their unique
identities and designs and so much
effort is put into them and they just
all look so fantastic except for a
glitch is a glitch because if you look
at the nightosphere if you look at the
crystal dimension if you look at even
where prismo lives like just that cube
like even all of that stuff like they're
all incredibly unique yeah
they don't try to toss in like oh look
we have you know that's here that's also
in this world they're all entirely
unique and this is another one where
it's like yeah that's why i was actually
like can we get to a good one because I
knew poo boy was a really it's one of my
favorite episodes what am i - it just
sort of has like everything in it and
it's like it doesn't amount to a very
serious ending but it's still there
still strangely enough kind of a lot of
weight to it
you know uh and especially considering
their pillows yeah to observe silly kid
back to life just to hurt okay um yeah
what and I love the idea I always like
you know something I love about like you
know an Arnie our Alice in Wonderland
stuff it's I love how do you get to the
world you know the different world and
just a pillow for it oh it's you
genius it's ingenious when he was
climbing in there I'm like oh I hope you
like I hope it's like 10 times bigger
and he finds something else and just
when you see the whole world and it's
like I love that it's so imagine it but
it's so clever and it just it takes it
takes so much effort to make an episode
like this this strange but also kind of
this heavy and this funny and they all
have like the same amount it's not like
well it was mostly serious and kind of
funny or it was you know the kind of
series of mostly but it was very much
like it was just equal amounts yeah like
perfectly proportionate and you're just
saying well this is gay and not serious
note or a joke no joke no but it's it's
still fine it's still hilarious so yeah
I love with you I think it's one of my
favorite episodes um I liked a lot of
the jokes like when he finally crawled
something so I got Jake turns around
it's gone he's like man did he build
this - he really need to get some other
girlfriends or something yeah that or
one adult finish cutting down the tree
and it falls and lands on the cow or
horse and just bounces and he runs he
goes are words like punts this is like I
like the tie nor he cuts the blanket
dragon and it bleeds all the feathers
and he's like oh that it like it's a lot
of the little tiny jokes that I really
enjoyed through a BMO with the cups with
the giant rainbow wigs and all that
stuff like it was I think this is like I
said one of my favorite episodes it hit
like on every mark yeah so for me this
is actually Lea one of my top five I say
so - actually I mean it seems like
strange episode because it's like it's
la there is a lot we - it's still not
like it's not and I remember you you
know or something like that but it's
still like just it just feels so
complete you just are watching like yeah
that was just like a perfect episode
yeah yeah so ya know uh good stuff more
that part of me a while ago make out
with my pillow wife sure her come on no
I do not